steve's with us in houston
hey steve what's up good afternoon
gentlemen thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help earlier this year
my mother was diagnosed with dementia
and because she was unable to care for
herself we had to move her from her home
in florida
to where i live here in texas and i
she's now in an
assisted living we just sold her house
for a december close
and i just found out that my brother
who's in the will
has requested his inheritance after the
closing of the house
i was going to take the proceeds as her
power of attorney take those proceeds
and invest them
so we can make sure that she has enough
money for her care
because of the dementia we feel she may
be moved into a memory care facility
which
yeah the cost for those go up
dramatically from what i understand yeah
and i was just wondering is is it common
to ask for your
inheritance early is it even legal well
you can ask for it but you're the power
of attorney
correct uh if you choose to distribute
some of your mother's wealth to her
children that would be
in um violation of your fiduciary
responsibility which is to take care of
her with her money
you can't do this legally you would be
subject to lawsuit
if she comes up short of money to take
care of her and you gave your brother
the money
the other siblings are coming after you
or they could
you see i
i don't think i'd see it okay well
you're you're the power of attorney
now you'll have to ask an attorney but
this is correct okay i'm not practicing
law here i'm the power of attorney on a
bunch of crap
and so when you're the power of attorney
it means you are you have what's called
a fiduciary
trust responsibility which means you
are to act in the best interest of the
person
whom you are power for in this case your
mom
understand okay if you do not do that
you could be liable for soup by anyone
that has harmed
that is harmed by you doing that so an
example would be
you choose to give your brother his
share of the inheritance out of this
before she has passed and then she comes
up short on money
and the other siblings have to chip in
to take care of mom they have now been
harmed
by your inappropriate handling of this
money because you didn't ask act in her
best interest
because you already told us what's in
her best interest she might need the
that is money so you legally have to
tell him no to protect yourself
wow excellent well okay which is what
you wanted to do anyway
but yeah i mean steve you you're not
going to allow your brother's wants
to get in the way of what your mom needs
and and that's just the bottom line
so you would have him how many siblings
do you all have
well it's just my brother and the
grandkids that are in the will
my sisters and i are not in the will
because we have kids well we have kids
that are in the wheelbarrow oh your kids
are in the well instead of you
personally
then the kids would be the one whoever
which stands to benefit from the money
that is going to be uh messed up if she
needs money and doesn't have any could
come
could come after you so what you would
do is check with the the way to handle
this relationally
is talk to the attorney that drew the
will up and verify what i just told you
to be true
and then you can go back and you don't
have to say i talked to dave ramsey
because dave ramsey don't know nothing
right
so you just talk to say i talked to the
attorney and the attorney says i would
be liable if we come up
short and i'm not willing to take that
chance so you'll just have to wait
by the way an inheritance technically
speaking is what happens when someone
dies
if there's any money left yeah and so
jesus people get a will
draw up a will this is a prime example
some people should
what can happen if you don't have it
it's important
go to daveramsey.com i'm glad glad mama
had a will
gladship power of attorney and she gave
it to the right kid she did it the right
way
yeah great kid got it cause he got sense